this is Startalk here we go this is from
Scott and that's all he says this this
is from Scott okay he says on your
premiere of Cosmos you mentioned that
the moon was pushed away by tidal
friction can you explain that a little
bit further I had never heard it put
like that before yep I push there's a
very visual image but what's really
happening is that it's getting flung
flung is a more sort of physically
accurate thing right so what's going on
is that moon creates a tidal bulge on
earth and so it the water that's nearest
the moon pulls towards the moon the moon
is pulling on earth a little less and
the water that's on the other side of
the Moon is pulling on even less so all
the oceanic waters form this bulge that
it's in a direct line to the moon okay
okay all right
it turns out it's not under direct line
to the moon because earth is rotating
and we're rotating faster than the moon
is turning around it so we actually drag
this bulge ahead of the moon okay okay
okay so this bulge is actually trying to
slow us down that's why we occasionally
add leap seconds to the calendar gotcha
and because the Bulge is a head of the
Moon right the moon feels a
gravitational force ahead of it and so
it wants to go faster in its orbit right
and by going faster in its orbit it
ascends to higher distances from earth
gotcha so it's a it's a it's a cosmic
ballet choreographed by the forces of
gravity gosh darn it that was phantom
ooh is spiraling away about five inches
a year from Earth just because of this
flinging effect right of the leading
edge of this tidal bulge right Oh Mike
that is fascinating because it's like
the earth is a container holding this
wall yes yes correct so instead of
lining up with the with the with the
gravitational pull from the balloon
because the earth is a container holding
this water and it's spinning yes the
water wants to move ahead with dragons
were ahead of the water ahead of the
moon and that costs us our rotational
energy to do so oh my god that's that's
incredible
well it's just physics I know but you
know I don't do that a lot you know you
would you look like a demo you look like
a double rainbow guy remember double
rainbow guy it comes around the corner
on the mountain it's on you too this was
crying I say dude it's physics okay oh
this is divine no it's like it's white
alright so so I don't mean to take away
the beauty of this by the way there are
other things that are mysteries that we
don't understand right that are even
more beautiful but I'm saying like women
we heard in this tango with the moon
right ultimately if the when the moon
wins what's not gonna win ultimately the
moon wants to slow us down so much that
we rotate at exactly the same rate that
the moon orbits us right and when that's
the case our tidal bulbs will align we
will not be fighting the Bulge and the
bulbs will not be flinging the moon
forward and the system will be called
will be in what it's called a double
tidal lock double title lock yeah which
was arrested I was I was I wanted to
invent to that move what I used to
Russell the double title hi Russell and
I'd know astrophysics you know I was
trying to invent a double title lock
wrestling hold right yeah so so what so
what happen at that point
Earth Day will equal the lunar month guy
and one side of the earth will only ever
face the moon just as today one side of
the moon only ever faces the earth which
is why there is never her eyes on the
moon right always in the skies if you're
on that half of the moon that's it yeah
that's which is why that famous photo
called Earthrise taken by Apollo 8 in
December 1968
that's called Earthrise because the
earth was rising over the moon why butts
because they were
right there orbiting the moon is that a
tip hole up the camera and there's earth
rising that's how you get earth rise but
people thought
earth rises on the moon just like the
moon rises on earth not now right
that's an amazed not until the moon wins
unfortunately I'm still stuck on double
tidal locking I'm trying to figure out
like do you put your like legs around
the purses net and then you're like
hanging off of their back and then you
grab both their knees and you like whip
it and you know I got no I'll show you
off-camera I'll show I never perfected
it but I had I had the ideas of one it
was good that's pretty cool all right
that what happens is you face your
opponent and then I swing you till
you're out of balance and then take you
down while I'm still facing you because
in a double title lock both sides of the
orbs are facing another that no matter
what they do so the idea is to get the
person still facing you and then as ice
when you swing them down right yeah this
is Startalk